after Marvin Prince is with Department
of Horticulture at Cornell and is our
very expert here in New York State and
this week he's going to talk about
fuller full-year testing and visual
assessment of nutrients and establish
parity plantains
Oh
get ready to go Marvin oh sure I'm okay
okay I'm gonna wait till my clock here
says two o'clock just good people Oh as
am i running early I think okay
thanks everyone for joining us today's
topic is foliar testing and sampling and
very crops it's going to be a little bit
technical in places so feel free to use
the box and chat box and submit your
questions that way
so just to review the principles we have
talked about up at this point we talked
about soil testing how that's most
useful prior to planning or we adjust
our pH and adjust our nutrient levels
now what we want to start talking about
as lief analysis which is most
appropriate once the planting is
established
we like leaf analysis better than soil
analysis for established plants because
it actually determines what the plan
itself has taken up and so it's a little
bit more accurate assessment of nutrient
status than estimating availability from
the chemical extractant so if the
chemical extractants do for the soil is
they try to mimic but the route takes up
well if you have the actual plant taking
up the nutrient why not use the plant
instead of the extractant that's the
logic there it's particularly important
in perennial crops where nutrients that
are taken up one year can be stored in
reserve and used again in subsequent
years where our soil test doesn't really
tell you what the plant is going to do
with the nutrient once it's taken up so
the fuller testing is much better for
assessing nutrient status and
established perennial plants and it's
based on a simple principle and that is
look at what the nutrient levels are in
the leaf tissue and compare it to a
standard it's no different than getting
your cholesterol tested at the doctor's
office you know what sort of a normal
range is and we can look and see if we
fall within that and if we're too high
or too low we can do something about it
and we have standard ranges for
strawberries for raspberries for the
blueberries for all sorts of crops and
we'll look and see if our nutrient falls
within that range and that seems pretty
simple and straightforward we'll deal
with these numbers a lot more detail in
two weeks but just want to give you a
sense that these standards do exist the
basis for the standards are the same
from lab to lab and so we don't have
this issue like we do with soils where
it really depends on the extraction
method as to what your results are going
to say I'm going to tell you everybody
pretty much use the same type of
analysis they use of these inductively
coupled plasma spectrometers to look at
the amount of nutrients in a particular
amount of tissue and the way this works
in a thing I think of most is when at
least when I was a kid we had a
fireplace and we had this little bag of
chemicals that had different minerals in
there and we would throw it into the
fire and a fire would glow different
colors it would be green and red and
orange and yellow depending on what the
nutrient was that we threw in there and
it's the same principle with these icps
it takes a leaf it heats up the material
in that leaf to really hot temperature
the minerals glow and you can use that
spectrophotometer to see how much of a
glow you have in certain color ranges in
spectra and that tells you how much of
that particular element you have so it's
pretty slick process it's the tissue
ranges that we have or derive from
healthy plants they're usually not
empirically derived and what I mean by
that is people don't go out and do a lot
of different experiments so they put
different rates of say potassium and
different rates of calcium at different
rates of magnesium on the soil and look
and see how the plants respond to that
take tissue samples along that range and
then see what's optimal that's too much
work and too much detail and too many
interactions are possible so most of the
time these numbers come from plants that
look healthy growing healthy look great
they take its sample we see what those
values are and by doing that lots of
lots and lots of times we can kind of
get a sense of what those ranges are for
healthfully growing plants and when we
sample those leaves we want to take them
at a time when the leaf nutrient values
are stable so when our loop nutrient
values stable well we'll talk about that
at second because that depends on some
things but in terms of measuring the
values in the leaves everything works
well with this ICP except for nitrogen
and sulfur and those are the exceptions
there's different methods that exists a
major nitrogen and sulfur leaves
different ways of digesting the leaves
to pull out the nitrogen and sulfur and
different tools use to measure the
amounts we can use color metric expect
of atomic methods we can use specific
ion electrodes that you can stick it in
the solution and measure how much
ammonium ion is there or we can do some
combustion and see what results on that
but the values that you get for these
different methods are pretty closely
correlated and so people don't worry too
much about it a sulfur in particular
even though there are differences with
these methods or it's rare that you ever
get a software deficiency and so we
don't worry about that so much and
nitrogen there were it's pretty closely
correlated to other things the the
nitrogen comes in two different forms it
comes in this ammonium form an organic
form which is biologically active and
then it comes in a nitrate form and the
total of the nitrate and ammonium form
gives you a total amount of nitrogen
it's the nitrate form that's not very
active in the plant it's moved into the
plant but it's not really converted it
has to be converted into products that
are biologically active so really when
we measure nitrogen in a leaf we really
want to know how much NH 4 plus is there
that's the biologically active form but
determining that is pretty expensive and
the nitrate concentration in plants is
generally pretty low it's mostly just in
the xylem vessels so off
times the cheapest way to do it is just
look at total nitrogen and assume that's
really highly correlated almost the same
as ammonium biologically active nitrogen
and that's what most leaf analysis are
based on so there's a little bit of
error for nitrogen and the same with
sulfur but we don't worry about too much
oh one of these leaf values most stable
a little movie sample leaves well we
don't want to do it when the plants are
growing rapidly because the levels are
fluctuating all over place and nutrients
are moving around to growing points and
things just aren't stable when plants
are growing rapidly and similarly when
they're rooting the values are jumping
all over the place because you've got a
lot of export of things like potassium
from leaves to fruit and fruit expansion
it so things are fluctuating all over
the place so we need to find times when
there's not a lot of rapid growth and
there's not a lot of food expansion so
for strawberries the best time seems to
be after harvest that sort of that
renovation time when the new leaves
start to grow out of the plant after
renovation you've got a lot of rapid
growth in strawberry in the spring and
of course they fruit right away and so
none of those times and made in June and
July really very good but august early
august is using a good time late july
when those new leaves emerge it gives
its a good indication of the nutrient
status of the plant raspberries whether
it's summer bearing or fall bearing
raspberries that August Tom [ __ ] seems
to be the best again most rapid growth
happens in the spring for both summer
and fall fruiting raspberries the summer
bearing raspberries are pretty much done
ball bearing raspberries haven't started
yet so if we sample leaves from the
prime Akane's not the floor canes the
prime Akane's in early August is a good
time to sample because value is stable
the same way with blueberries fruits
already expanded we might still have
fruit in a plant but we don't have a lot
of expansion of the fruit at that time
and most of the growth is stopped at
that time so August is a good time to
sample for those two and we select the
most recently mature lead if we select
older leaves those were growing during a
time of rapid growth or fruit expansion
so the values there might not be
representative but the recently matured
leaves at those times are the best we
collect about 30 to 50 leaflets without
the petioles because a petiole sort of
dilute what's in the leaves we just want
the lament of the lead randomly sample
the area that you're going to
be interested in you can either do it as
a diagnostic basis where I'm going to
just sample from plants that look sick
to see what's wrong or routine is just I
want to see what the health of this
planet is so you just randomly go
through the area and pick 50 leaflets
again the young leaves exposed to Sun
and when you get those leaves it's best
to wash them off and distilled water to
get rid of dust soil the amount of
splashing leaf or fungicide residue
because a lot of fungicides have
elements in it metal elements in them so
I'm going to wash those off and they can
just go into a paper bag and dry for a
couple of days and they can be sent to a
lab some people send us samples that
they try to preserve them green and uh
you know almost put them in a press and
press them down at all and send them
with some moisture in a plastic bag we
don't need that we're going to dry them
as soon as we get them so you might as
well go ahead and dry them anyway and
it's easier to handle that way
there are several advantages is foliar
testing and I alluded to them already
standardization of analyses you don't
have this difference from lab to lab if
you send leaves to one lab you get
results back they ought to be the same
results are really close to it as
another lab now the recommendations
might be different we'll talk about
those the next webinar but the number is
ought to be pretty much the same better
indicator of nutrient status and a soil
test the thing I like about it is it can
identify potential problems before they
result in visible symptoms or reduce
growth and yield so it's just like the
cholesterol test of your blood you can
detect high cholesterol before you know
anything's even wrong with you before
you have that heart attack or hardening
of the arteries or whatever and it can
help diagnose a problem if you see
something that doesn't look right in
your field off-color plants aren't
growing well you don't think it's a
virus or you just don't know what it is
you can just sample from that area at
least get a sense of whether nutrients
are involved
revenue sir there's a question on how do
you suggest to dry the sample I don't
think you have to do anything special to
dry it just put it in a bag and leave in
a window seal or send it in the way it
is put it on a radiator idono it just
has to be dry we just don't want it to
get them all you know in a plastic bag
where it's really wet and they start to
mold
there are several shortcomings of foliar
testing and one is these aren't real big
shortcomings but there you should be
aware of it it provides the total amount
of an element not the amount that is in
a biologically active form and for
certain mineral elements we have
biologically active and inactive forums
and iron is one of those it's probably
the most important of the mineral
elements it occurs in two forms and if
you had you know high school chemistry
or college chemistry you might remember
that iron is a divalent ion it comes in
two forms there's a plus to form in a
plus three form in plants is the plus to
form that's active and not the plus
three form but ideally we want to know
when we measure iron how much iron is in
the plus to form but the ICP doesn't
tell us that it just tells us what the
total amount of iron is so there are
situations where we can see that iron
levels look like they're high or
adequate but really we have symptoms
behind chlorosis because most of the
iron is not in that correct form and we
talked about this two webinars ago we
talked about blueberries and high
calcium soils how the calcium wishes a
lot of the iron into plant to the plus
three form where it's not really active
so on a blueberry plant showing iron
chlorosis you might see that you have
adequate iron but really you still have
on chlorosis because it's not right for
the other short coming is that we're
sampling at one time of the year when
the values of these nutrients tend to be
the most stable but that might not be
the most ideal time for all elements it
might be for certain elements that it's
better to sample first thing in a spring
or maybe going into the fall but it's
too expensive to do these samplings over
multiple times and the way the ICP
analysis works it does all the nutrients
that one shot just runs it through and
they get a proud of everything at one
time so it's not like we do each element
individually so each time we do a test
it's expensive you know its twenty to
thirty dollars so we don't want to be
doing at multiple times during the
season unless you have a really good
reason for it
and most of the standards have been
developed for just those times of the
year that we talked about earlier but it
might not be ideal for everything and
then thirdly it doesn't mean that if you
do a leaf test folder test you can avoid
doing the soil test we still need that
soil test to be meaningful the next
webinar will give you some examples of
how just looking at a foliar test you
can maybe draw some wrong conclusions
until you look at that soil test and we
talked in previous webinars about how
the pH has a big impact on what the
plants take up these foliar tests are
really only good if the soil pH is
within the range that we recommend
sure coming of a foliar analysis it
doesn't really measure interactions
among elements that can affect activity
and bioavailability so we know for
example that potassium can be potassium
is really high in a plan it can reduce
the activity of magnesium again a leaf
analysis might show the magnesium is
adequate but if the past is really high
that magnesium activity might be
suppressed so it doesn't behave as if
magnesium is adequate other well known
interactions are iron and phosphorus
zinc and phosphorus and we're already
mentioned calcium and iron how they are
antagonistic particularly in blueberries
when we were trying to grow things of a
lower pH
there's another question marvin on ph
and should should the soil pH be sampled
at the same time as the leaves or do you
just use your most recent soil test you
can use your most recent soil test the
soil pH isn't going to change that much
over period of months unless you've
added a lot of limas offer recently but
just your standard soil test it's going
to be pretty much the same in the spring
as it is in or in fall is it would even
be the next year when you do your leaf
analysis in August so your most recent
soil tests will be adequate for
determining that range and you need
a caveat we're talking about these
nutrients and deficiencies in all is it
usually more than one nutrient is
deficient at a time it's pretty unusual
do this to see one by itself although
you can see it but oftentimes conditions
that induce deficiencies and impacted
more than just one nutrient and a simple
example would be a high pH if you put on
too much lime and you kick that pH up
too high you'll see simultaneous
deficiencies of iron manganese copper
bronze ink and phosphorus
for a bunch of essential elements in
plants and they're all important because
they all carry out functions that are
critical and I'm not going to read
through all these but you can glance it
to chart and see that wow there's a lot
of things that happen in a plant
biochemically and these elements have
big impacts on that point out potassium
is the only one it's not really
incorporated into the plant itself it's
not really part of enzymes is not part
of DNA it's not part of cell structure
very much it's mainly used for Ozma
regulation and for catalyzing enzyme
reactions more than fifty enzymes in a
plant are activated by potassium it
helps open and close stowe mates so it's
really important in photosynthesis but
it's not incorporated into parts of the
plant most of these other ones are
incorporated as some extent I molybdenum
mostly for enzyme activation it's kind
of interesting to look and see how the
plants have evolved to use these
essential elements in so many diverse
ways and all kind of works together and
make sense and plants grow a pretty
fascinating stuff other essential
nutrients that weren't on that chart
power molybdenum chlorine and nickel
these were among the most recently
discovered essential nutrients people
didn't really know they were critical
until fairly recently but they're only
really necessary in very small amounts
in fact the amounts are so small that
experimentally it was actually hard to
grow plants in media that didn't contain
at least tiny amount of nickel or
molybdenum
certain other plants not all plants
sodium selenium cobalt and silicon are
essential nutrients but not in the berry
crops are going to be talking about so
we don't worry about those four except
maybe selenium and sodium in situations
where we have too much we're in toxic
situations but we have zero of those we
never would happen if theoretically if
we would it wouldn't make an impact on
the plant
this chart here shows that relative
concentrations of the various nutrients
and atoms and healthy plant tissue a
relative to nickel molybdenum which if
there's one atom of nickel and went out
of molybdenum we would have about two of
cobalt 100 of copper 300 sink and you
can read through that all the way up to
where we're getting too into like
nitrogen where we have a million atoms
I'm nitrogen for every atom of
molybdenum with a nickel 30 million
oxygen 40 million carbon 60 million
hydrogen so one of the challenges in
leaf analysis is a test it measures
concentration cross such a wide range of
like a millionfold range of nutrient
concentrations and I think we're
fortunate we have technology that allows
us to do it as cheaply as we do or
nutrients across such a wide wide range
you
eal symptoms of deficiencies now certain
nutrients are extremely mobile in the
plant and this characteristic can help
diagnose the visual symptoms you might
see so there are five nutrients that are
really very mobile nitrogen phosphorus
potassium magnesium and sulfur since
their mobile they will tend to move out
of the leaf into the phloem and into the
growing points so as you recall the
xylem is what pulls water into the plant
and with it it pulls in some nutrients
it goes up the xylem into the leaf where
all this biochemical activity happens
sugars are made your photosynthesis and
then the nutrients the amino acids that
are made that nutrients that need to go
to the growing points are pumped out
through the phloem and they go
preferentially to the growing points so
if you see a plant that has odd colors
and old leaves but to new leaves seem to
be healthy and vigorous it's just these
old leaves are turning yellow are doing
funky things that's almost always a
deficiency in NPK magnesium or sulfur
because they're mobile we see the
opposite if we see the young leaves
showing deficiencies in the old leaves
not that using implies it's one of the
other nutrients because they're less
mobile and we'll look at some pictures
of these in a minute
you
in order to show you some SAP values of
substances that you squeeze the SAP out
of the plant what you get and this this
is separated based on xylem sap and
phloem sap and as on them is what comes
in from the roots it goes up through the
plan into the leaf and then the phloem
is what comes out of lead so let's look
at a few of these let's look at sugars
to begin with just to give you a feel
for how the plant works you know the
plant does it take sugar Alice soil
there's zero sugar in the xylem but when
it leaves a leaf in the phloem there's
lots of sugar there so essentially you
know the water is coming up to those on
into the phloem into the leaf or sugars
are made and then that's pumped out the
flow so you see those big differences
between the xylem and phloem
octo last few webinar is about nitrate
as a fertilizer this is an example of
design them versus the phloem when you
fertilize a plant with nitrate sources
of nitrogen the nitrate goes into the
plant and it's dissolved in the water it
goes into the plant so it goes right
into the plant up through the route into
the vascular system into the leaf at
fairly high concentrations but when it
comes out of leaf there is none of it
nitrate doesn't move through the phloem
when it's in the leaf it's converted to
nitrate reductase into amino acids and
ammonium compounds any four compounds so
when it comes out of leaf what we see
our values over here being high and up
here amino acids NH 4 but not nitrate
itself because that conversion happens
in the lead
there's been some work on determining
nitrogen needs by measuring the petiole
sap concentration of nitrate you may
have heard about petiole nitrate
analysis the petiole sap analysis what
people are trying to do is we're trying
to look at this value here
determine the nitrogen needs of the
plant and they've done this a strawberry
particularly to see if it works you can
get correlations with the total nitrogen
ease of the plant but the few problems
is that one is this isn't the type of
nitrogen that the plant uses the plant
uses this type of nitrogen in fact that
nitrate isn't going to the growing point
so it's coming in but it's not
necessarily going I'll leave so is this
really the best indicator of the plants
nutritional status it's a measure of
nitrogen availability but not
necessarily nitrogen use
oh it's not necessarily correlated with
the active form of nitrogen we look at
the sap concentration and the other
thing that happens is the concentration
is really dependent on the flow of water
in asylum so after it rains the value of
nitrate in the xylem is low and then
when it starts to dry out the plants not
taking up as much water the
concentration of nitrate goes up so the
day-to-day basis those values and the
sap it is on them change so it's really
hard to say whether something's
deficient or not or needs more nitrogen
just based on these snapshot pictures at
one point in time in this really
variable concentration so for certain
crops this petiole analysis people are
using it like in corn and some of the
annual crops but in perennial crops it
hasn't really caught on because each
time you take a sample you've got to run
a expensive test it's not always
correlated its variable I just wanted to
mention that because you probably have
heard of it before go back to these
ranges for sap again look at that if we
look at silam phosphorus we see that it
comes into the plant at a fairly low
concentration it goes out of the leaf
into the phloem at a fairly high
concentration so phosphorus is fairly
mobile comes in it's accumulating a leaf
and it's sent out at high concentrations
to the growing points fosters very
mobile nutrient in the plant
name is potassium potassium is really
mobile comes into the plant do the
dissolved to be dissolved in the water
comes into plant goes up tues island
into the leaf it's concentrated a great
extent sent out the phloem at high
concentrations again these growing
points the feeling the fruit this is all
really intensive for potassium plays a
big role in that so we see high
concentrations in the flow
awesome calcium is just the opposite it
comes into the plant you dissolve water
through mass flow it goes out to phloem
and even lower concentrations then it
comes into the plant to the dissolved
walk through the dissolved water so it's
not a very mobile nutrient in the plant
so when we look for deficiencies of
calcium we see calcium deficiencies
develop at the extremities of the plant
where it just doesn't move through very
well it doesn't move through that phloem
and gets to the extremities it's just it
doesn't move through the plant very well
so it's not a very mobile nutrient
let's start looking at some of these
photographs and see if we can't figure
something out based on the plant and the
behavior of the nutrient so I was
something fairly simple and blueberry
here a plant with adequate nitrogen and
a plant with an adequate nitrogen and
most people are trained enough they can
look at the color of the plant and they
can say well that's just that green just
tells me that there's not enough
nitrogen in the plant and the leaves are
smaller they tend to be yellower in some
plants like strawberry the leaf color a
little bit more red than light green in
more advanced stages of nitrogen
deficiency
this is a field of strawberries that was
sort of abandoned the grower wasn't
didn't renovate it I had probably
fertilized it since last year renovation
and so the leaves are starting to show
this reddish yellowish light green color
indicating nitrogen deficiency
offer is a deficiency that mimics
nitrogen its software is a component of
amino acids just like nitrogen bulk of
nitrogen is and amino acids and so the
two are actually in parallel they both
are comprised amino acids it's just that
software is needed in a lot lower amount
of nitrogen and as I mentioned earlier
sulfates and sulfur are pretty BIC whatz
around the world a lot of lot of our
soils have soft baits in them there's
lots of software in a soil we live in an
area where there's deposition of sulfur
and a rainfall because we still burn
coal and stuff and that you know sulfur
dioxide floats over the Northeast and
when it rains software comes down
fertilizers contain sulfur so even
though we don't measure it real well and
a lot of the soil tests don't show
sulfur even on the result Wow usually we
just don't worry about it would only be
in situations where the soils are a real
sandy and there's a lot of rainfall we
might run into a software deficiency but
the symptoms look very similar to what
they look like if nitrogen was deficient
as a principal the same you short on
amino acids in chlorophyll
source deficiency it's pretty similar in
most plants they developed the same kind
of symptoms with phosphorus deficiency
and that is that personage usually the
leaves turn a dark green or survive they
get this dark red coloration
um err you can see on the margins of the
leaves mild deficiencies that I just
starts to develop along the edges this
dark color eventually the whole leaf
will get dark red and on blueberry again
just a darker color than would be normal
even you can just sort of tell when you
look at that plant that it's more than
just you know too much nitrogen it's
just a darker green and again when you
look at the leaf you'll see that
phosphorous is love we don't usually
have too much phosphorus deficiency in
our soils in the Northeast particularly
because there are a lot of dairy farms
around and people you know spread manure
and the newer has a lot of phosphorus in
it a lot of rocks have a lot of
phosphorus in it it's not that common
that I see a soil test farms our leaf
analysis come back where phosphorus is
really low usually it's adequate or
maybe close to being low but not really
seriously the petition
however on this nutrient here at
potassium we do C deficiency symptoms
occasionally this is of course
strawberry and the first sign of
deficiency is often a little bit of
browning where the leaflet attaches to
the petiole and the leaf gets a little
blotchy here and you can see over here
just its dark green in places like being
in places and then as time goes on get a
little bit more marginal burning here
you can see is long the edge you get
this marginal burning you can see the
darker color the lighter color and in
marginal Bernie very indicative a
potassium deficiency and since potassium
is a very mobile nutrient in the plant
you see the symptoms developing on the
older leaves first same will be true
with phosphorous the older leaves first
because it's a mobile nutrient within
the plant
on the field potassium deficiency again
that marginal burning is very indicative
of that
and blueberries marginal burning
original burning s these leaves are very
low in potassium so that's common
symptom in almost every plan
okay look at what calcium deficiency
looks like now if you recall I said that
calcium does not move very well in the
plant it can move through the plant in
two different ways and come up to the
xylem move into leaf or it can be pushed
through the phloem into the growing
points the problem here is that that
growing points themselves when calcium
is in short supply the calcium just
doesn't get out to the tips so real
distinctive calcium deficiency you see
the growing points turning brown they
don't have enough calcium here you see
it here you see it here there's just not
enough calcium getting out it doesn't
move through the phloem very well anyway
and if you have cloudy humid conditions
it doesn't move through the xylem very
well either because transpiration is
shut down whenever it's cool and cloudy
and humid so you're not sucking water
into the plant and bringing calcium in
through mass flow and it doesn't move
through the flow and very well anyway so
the growing points are the first things
that suffer and calcium is in short
supply and because it's not a very
mobile nutrient we also see it on the
new growth first before we see it on the
old growth so here is a new leaf coming
out of a strawberry plant it's already
impacted by low calcium it's already
turning brown and black and hasn't even
emerged at the older leaves on the
strawberry plant would have been fine
because they already got their calcium
calcium doesn't move out a lead so
they're hanging on to it so they look
fine but these new leaves under the
short cows and supply show the symptoms
because the calcium is not remote alized
and here we see a runner tip again
another common place where you'll see
calcium deficiency showing up you see
this necrosis of the tips and the
runners are way out there it's hard for
calcium get out that far along this
runner so you'll see symptoms showing up
here as well
hi Museum magnesium is similar to
calcium as both a divalent cation but my
name is more mobile in the planet in
calcium so doesn't quite have that same
tendency to show up in the newer growth
first but cap magnesium and almost all
plant shows a pretty distinctive symptom
and that is you get interval coloring
and eventually browning so on this
blueberry plant we can see that the
color between the veins is kind of red
in the vein stay green very common plans
with magnesium deficiency green veins
this colored interv a neural areas first
thing to think of is I use a deficiency
and we call this sort of the Christmas
tree pattern because it's got the green
almost like a Christmas tree and in
between is red
we have the beginnings of magnesium
deficiency on strawberry unlike
blueberry we don't get that really
strong red color in between the veins
but we do get intervene Oh coloring one
on the veins but in between the veins
and as we go a little bit more severe
situation we can see that in between the
veins actually turn brown but all this
anytime you see it's interv anal
browning it's a nutrient deficiency you
know oh that's magnesium because that's
how it behaves
marvin jeff from oneida county had a
question on the going back to calcium
deficiency ok on the strawberries and
whether the think the first picture you
showed showed a little bit of cupping is
that as symptom of the calcium
deficiency yes it is yeah because out
here at the corners of the edges you
know those leaves those cells they're
just haven't developed and so the leaf
wants to expand but the tips of the
leaflet are still not developing so the
plant tried the back part here tries to
expand this part doesn't want to go
along with it so you end up with these
cups which again symptomatic of low
calcium in the plant it doesn't
necessarily mean that there's low
calcium in the soil it just means that
it's not getting into the leaf and
getting out to those tips often this is
a symptom of this inadequate irrigation
or off and on again irrigation as
opposed to low calcium in the soil but
we'll talk more about that next week
you
oh this is a photograph
I'll tell you what is just yet but it's
a real good example of how a nutrient
deficiency develops in the younger
leaves first these new younger leaves
coming out where the older leaves you
know don't show the deficiency and this
is iron deficiency and again it's not a
very mobile nutrient so it stays in your
leaves they've got there they're not
going to share there's new leads to come
out or wanting some and they're not
going to get it from the older leave so
they stay yellow very classic symptoms
of iron deficiency is this just general
yellowing yeah it is between the veins
like magnesium but it's a little bit
different look to it the veins state
greenness interview areas very yellow
it's not sort of a red or a light green
it's just yellow which indicates that
it's probably are
a kidney youngest lead
ah enemies asking about in cold springs
blueberries are purple leaves yeah that
doesn't indicate a nutrient deficiency
usually that's just cold temperature and
chlorophyll development usually as soon
as the weather warms up that our color
goes away and it leaves appear normal
yeah that is often mistaken for
phosphorus deficiency when people see
that red color and the spring that they
oh it's phosphorus deficiency but it's
not it's just plants just need to warm
up
what's up of iron deficiency fairly
common when blueberries are planted in
high pH soils
you
you
he's deficiency we don't see this as
much or very much it also appears on
younger leaves first it's very much like
iron in terms of his mobility in the
plant and here are just some examples of
what it might look like on a strawberry
leaf a raspberry leaf blackcurrant and
you can see it's almost like iron and in
fact you might assume it was iron and
again it's these things aren't perfectly
distinctive from one another so that's
why we do go foliar analysis it helps us
tell park what's going on here you know
something's not right but you can't
always tell by the visual symptoms what
it is but we do see manganese deficiency
occasionally particularly when the soil
pH is too high
zinc deficiency I couldn't find a good
photograph of zinc deficiency for Barry
crops but it is fairly common on entry
fruit crops particularly in sandier
soils I see it on apples and citrus
particularly citrus sorts growing on
sandy soils it they also call little
leaf disease just because the leaves
don't get as big as they need to or
should and they also see some
intervening a line with the zinc
deficiency
deficiency this is when we do see quite
a bit in Northeast the availability of
boron is quite variable in our soils and
we run into situations where it can be
low in fact it's one of them one of the
only micronutrients that we test for
particularly in strawberries because
although I get to my phone off you're
picking strawberries because it can be
low and it's an important nutrient for
plant growth so this is blueberry though
and this is a big grower in Maine had a
bunch of lil bush blueberries and II
kept telling me he always had winter
injury in his plant and indeed it does
look like winter injury and after a
particularly mild winter you called up
and said I still have wintered you I
can't believe it yeah good snow cover it
wasn't that cold we did a leaf analysis
boron was really low we applied boron
over his fields and next year no problem
whatsoever so this died back is very
characteristic of boron you see this die
back here I'll tell you why in a minute
this is a root system of a strawberry
plant that has all the nutrients in
needs it was grown in a water solution
hence the proliferation roots but the
next trick I'm going to show you is the
root system grown without boron
everything else is there but you can see
that root tips are really stubby that's
because boron is responsible for oxen
production which stimulates root growth
and cell elongation you don't have boron
you don't have good oxen activity
therefore you don't have good cell
expansion so you get these stubby little
root tips and of course roots like this
don't do a very good job of taking up
other nutrients either
the characteristic of boron deficiency
as a symmetrical leaves so I can lose
sleep over here you see the leaflet
tends to be smaller than normal anyway
but you often see this as symmetry
whereas in normal leaves with adequate
nutrition you don't get that as symmetry
and then this is a real severe case
where the leaves just fell to develop
again we don't have the cell elongation
that we would normally get when there's
enough oxygen present in the plant
and on the strawberry fruit itself the
little teens here excrete oxen which
causes the receptacle tissue underneath
to expand that's why the strawberry
plant or strawberry fruit grows and
turns into strawberry when these little
Achaeans are producing oxen you don't
get that expansion and so the food
becomes deformed so anything that
impacts these little Keynes whether it
be frost which kills the key in a
growing embryo or tarnish plant bug
feeding or low boron are going to give
you these deformed fruit again if you
just saw this you wouldn't really know
which of those three it was but when you
do a or poor pollination is up but or
then maybe those four things but a leaf
analysis could tell you whether it might
be blonde least you can rule it out
so I don't have any more toxicity
pictures to show you the efficiency
symptoms but I do have a warning for you
not to be fooled because herbicide
toxicity symptoms often resemble
nutrient deficiency symptoms so here I
have a picture of some plants that have
been affected by herbicide in this case
roundup in this case simazine in this
case sin bar in this case sola cam this
picture here is actually June yellows
it's a phytoplasma that impacts certain
varieties of strawberries it causes them
to turn yellow but what I wanted to do
is to show you that just because you see
that yellowing don't automatically
assume that it's a nutrient deficiency
it could be but check on the history of
the herbicide use it's also possible
that might be this photo plasm usually
you have patterns that you look for
herbicide injury usually occurs in a
regular pattern and field I see it often
at the end of rows where the tractor
that spraying the herbicide slows down
to make a turn and then you get a little
bit more herbicide you wanted at the end
a row for example every third row where
the sprayer might overlap with the
effort with the past and so you without
overlap is you get some injury symptoms
I've seen herbicide damage near wet
areas tell me well to figure out what
was going on but what was going on they
were spraying the herbicide when it was
wet when the tractor got into that
wetter area the wheel started to spin a
little bit the tractor slowed down but
the rate of herbicide coming out the
sprayer was the same so always right to
the side of these wet spots we see these
herbicide deficiencies or these
herbicide injury symptoms but uh it was
from that spare so you look for patterns
with herbicide usually the herbicide
injury has a rapid onset whereas the
nutrient deficiencies usually develop
more slowly and often follow the soil
type so my point is don't just
automatically assume it's a nutrient
deficiency even though it looks like
those pictures I just showed you
lastly I wanted to point out that over
fertilization can result in injury
symptoms as well here's here's some
photographs of some strawberry plants
they've been over lives with certain
nutrients so and it's photograph here
too much ammonium nitrogen fertilizer
the same way with this photograph here
down here we have too much boron and
again you get symptoms almost look like
potassium deficiency but actually in
this case here it's too much more on
over here too much zinc again looks like
it's a deficiency but really if you
overdo it you can have the same problem
as well and up here some of this
chlorosis that might look like you know
phosphorus deficiency is actually too
much copper so you've got to be really
careful just using visual assessment as
to what's going on so my take-home
message is that visual symptoms and
nutrient deficiencies are difficult to
diagnose and can be confused with many
other things once you try to address
these nutritional problems before visual
symptoms occur because once you start to
see the visual symptoms you know darn
well that yield has been affected in
plant growth has been affected and
lastly a foliar elemental analysis is
the best technology we currently have
for assessing plant nutrient status
Oh at the next webinar we're going to be
actually looking at some of the numbers
that come off of these foliar tests and
seeing if we can interpret them and
hopefully with the understanding you've
gotten today with how these nutrients
moving a plan how they interact you
would better able to interpret these
fully our tests we're going to look at a
couple of weeks
so this is the end of my formal remarks
and presentations if people want to type
in some questions we still a few minutes
to come up with some the answers
you
you
so I assume that means people are
understanding it and they're comfortable
with material so Diana you still out
there you can maybe come on and say a
few words yeah oh we do have one
question there
the question is the excess zinc look
like iron deficiency because the zinc is
interfering with iron uptake or is it
just coincidence that's a good question
i don't know the answer that i'll just
admit that's certainly possible that
since they're both divalent cations that
the zinc and iron could be interfering
with each other it's not one of those
common antagonisms that have been
written about or studied but I imagine
that's a possibility we have someone
else typing here as well these these
interactions in plants you know are not
that well studied particularly in berry
crops very few people have looked at it
so there's a lot of unanswered questions
out there when's the best time in which
leaves should be taken for strawberry
tissue analysis to mention earlier right
after renovation when those new leaves
come up out of the ground after harvest
that's usually late July maybe early
August that's the best time for
strawberry tissue analysis
hey it doesn't look like there's a any
other questions just a couple of quick
reminders so our next webinar will be on
December 16th it had been originally
scheduled for next week but will be on
the 16th again at two o'clock in the
afternoon and if anybody if this is the
first time you've joined us for one of
our webinars and haven't completed our
demographic form or the educator pretest
those are available as downloads under
that a file box and if you could please
complete those we would appreciate it
and then you can send those to Kathy
Hyden right so thank you everyone for
joining us this afternoon and we'll see
on the 16th